hey guys Pete here this is my recap and
review of mr. robot season 4 episode 3
titled 403 forbidden Elliott comes out
of a shell white rose as we know her is
born and Viera enters into the mix this
video will contain spoilers for
everything that happened in episode 3 so
don't watch this if you haven't seen
that yet I'll recap what happened
discussed why I think things are going
and then we can have a discussion about
it in the comments this episode picks up
with the flashback to 1982 where we
catch up with then director Jeong who is
meeting with IBM executives we get the
idea that he's intent on stealing
intellectual property for them and that
he has a close relationship with his
translator later we find out that
they're a couple and we watch his White
Rose reveals her true self as a trans
woman in their hotel room they have a
plan that won't work out because of
course it won't
Jarrell doesn't get the US Ambassador
post and her partner commits suicide
rather than going forward with a forced
marriage to a woman the whole sequence
was well crafted and it tied in with her
thought process as she's planning with
her assistant long Chu but I'm not sure
how White Rose having this tragic story
in her past is supposed to sit with us
at this point in the story we'll have to
wait and see if this is where they leave
it but I'd like to see more about how we
got here from there if you know what I
mean in the present timeline White Rose
decides not to wait for Elliot and price
to make a mistake instead he'll try to
force them into one by giving price what
he wants
they'll call a dais group meeting to
replace him on the next day which is
Christmas Day and there he will install
tyrell wellick as prices successor long
xu doesn't like the idea but White Rose
has made the decision so that's where
they leave it mr. robot is still the one
talking to us and he tells us about
Russian roulette and his fears about
Vera coming for them and the fact that
Elliot won't acknowledge any of that he
runs into Krista in the street and
things don't go well turns out Krista is
terrified of Elliot and doesn't want him
anywhere near her she feels that it's
necessary to make this very clear and
you can't help but feel for these
characters in this situation and this
all gets way more ominous when we
realize that one of Barris guys sees
them meet later we have a glimpse of
beer
he's up to his old tricks and when he
learns about the sighting with Krista we
know that he's gonna try to use her to
get to Elliot and get Elliot on his team
no big surprises here beerus still Saxon
will undoubtedly present a problem at
the worst time considering the clock is
ticking and there isn't much time left
before the project ships to the Congo
Darlene is with Elliot at allsafe and
she's all in to help as we learned in
Episode two she finds Susan Jacobs
contact at Cyprus National Bank
Olivia Cortez and explains that they
need to get physical access to her
laptop from work
Elliot refuses to let Darlene do the job
and there continues to be tension
between them
that all pretty much comes from Elliot's
end there's an interesting moment here
where Elliot tags in mr. robot to try
and talk Darlene out of doing the
breaking-and-entering herself when robot
playing the nice guy doesn't work Elliot
steps up himself and ends up scaring and
hurting Darlene when he grabs her it
isn't a good look for our hero and now
that there's another alter in play after
the last episode it's the kind of thing
that now makes you take a closer look
and wonder if he's cycling for what it's
worth they didn't do much to move the
other one plot along in this episode
after the reveal but it stood out to me
here how we have this new dynamic to
consider in all Elliot scenes and
interactions going forward
Elliot does break into Olivia's
apartment and finds the laptop he's
looking for unfortunately he needs
access to a security fob that generates
a unique RSA code if he wants to log
into it he also finds a bottle of
oxycontin in her bathroom and his dead
set on using this information against
her when they track her down at a bar as
we've seen a couple times this season
already mr. robot intervenes as the
voice of reason
instead of threatening her he offers to
buy her a drink and Elliot finds himself
reluctantly connecting with her things
almost fall apart when her OKCupid date
evan shows up you know classic Evan into
snowboarding social media influencing
and Reiki but after Elliot misses her
signal he comes around at the last
possible second and runs out after her
and gives her a kiss on the street which
leads to them going back to her place
back at her apartment they sleep
together and he waits for his
opportunity to get a hold of the fob and
send the code the Darlene and the man
she finds out that the dais meeting is
on for the next night and what follows
is a really strong scene where Elliot
and Lybia connect on a deep level as she
shows him the razor blade that she keeps
in the oxycontin bottle to remind
herself that if she hates herself enough
to start using again she might as well
kill herself
Elliot understands he knows what hating
yourself is like it's a fantastic scene
and it's always enjoyable to watch
Elliot stumble his way through the
process of connecting with someone this
is one of the reasons I've always been
so drawn to the show and that just made
me fear what the future may hold for
Olivia even more I mean I hope these two
will get some semblance of a happy
ending after watching this and I don't
even really care if they see each other
again but the context of him trying to
steal the fob to get access to dark army
accounts and her being the connection to
that doesn't bode well for this new
character at all I'm holding out hope
that her fate won't be similar to
shayla's or Angela's but it's not really
easy to do at this point after we leave
her apartment Elliot realizes he's being
followed by a white van he can't go back
to allsafe for fear giving up the
location so he decides to go home
instead when he arrives he finds the
door has been forced open he decides to
do what he would do if he had nothing to
hide only to find that it's Tyrell
inside waiting for him since tyrell
isn't Purvi to the new information that
Elliot is being followed he blurts out
that he's been named CEO and hey it's
good news because now we can take them
down from the inside
Elliot scrambles to write they're
listening on a notepad and the episode
ends with a shot of the band sitting
outside doing just that for the most
part this episode feels like a setup for
the dais meeting that almost has to
happen in the next episode it works as
that and it's not a bad standalone
episode either thanks to the human
connection aspects that we saw with
Olivia Tyrell becoming the CEO isn't
that surprising he's in a position where
the dark army feels like they can
control him so he checks out as far as
what they need going forward the vera
and krysta thing is just sort of like uh
I guess people have different
impressions of Viera the actor does a
fine job of working with this character
and he's a bad guy
there for that reason on some level this
just really kind of frustrates me though
that he's gonna go after Krista
especially after seeing this episode and
seeing how their interaction went down I
guess it's good that we got an idea of
what he's up to and he kind of stepped
in to take Tom's place because we didn't
get any of her story in this particular
episode I really did enjoy the scene
with Olivia and Elliot in her bathroom
and the one in the bar for that matter I
think one of the funniest things for me
was when he said not if you count the
heroin I did two days ago and she comes
back with what did someone hold you down
and force you to do it and he just
deadpans yeah that's pretty much what
happened and that really kind of
scratched that awkward Eliot itch for me
and how just how difficult it is for him
to interact with other people mr. robot
being the voice of reason once again
Elliot really seemed like he was on when
at the bar whenever he was going to use
the information about the drugs and hold
her relationship with her child over her
head it's refreshing to see mr. robot
actually being the guy who gets things
going in the right direction instead of
the reverse which is what we're used to
and that always this a much needed
healing in the end and his time as our
narrator mr. robot has been emphasizing
the danger of Elliot shutting everyone
off this came out again with Darlene in
this episode the one person who's
actually on his side and it felt like he
needed this little encounter to emerge
from the depths of his own head the
flashback like I said it was put
together well I especially liked the
thing commercial and the fact that they
used the song time from culture club the
wedding sending white roses as a joke
since those are typically for funerals
then the image of the red blood all over
them in the hotel with the reveal scene
framed by the mirrors behind her I mean
this was all designed really well the
more I think about it though I just
wonder it sort of makes White Rose
sympathetic and do we need her to be
sympathetic as the clear villain here I
don't know though I mean there may be
more that we see in her transformation
from that time to the present and it'll
make a little bit more sense
we're in episode three and it's
Christmas Eve the clock is definitely
ticking at this point we got like a bit
a runway in the number of episodes that
are left but not a lot of days in order
for it all to unfold so where you have
to expect that there's going to be some
flashbacks to fill up time but also that
as far as the stories related these
episodes are only going to account for
like a day or a half a day going to the
end I do have some real fears when it
comes to Olivia and what her fate might
be if you watch my trailer breakdowns
you know there's a lot of stuff that is
from future episodes in those trailers
that they put out before the season
started
I won't get spoilery here but there's
definitely some stuff to go back and
look at if you want to check those out
that gives us some hints as to things
that are gonna happen in the next couple
episodes I'm very interested to see
what's gonna happen at this dais meeting
who's gonna be there how that's going to
play out I'm wondering if there's gonna
be a detour between where this episode
ended and when that actually happens
based on how this episode ended but
we're gonna have to wait and see I think
this is another good episode I think
things are going in the right direction
and I am looking forward to episode 4
you may have noticed if you've been
following my recaps that this is pushed
back a little bit the other show that
I'm currently following Watchmen just
debuted it comes out first mr. robot
comes out second so that's pretty much
the most efficient way for me to do it
had some problems yesterday so it should
come out a little bit faster but if you
haven't watched Watchmen I would
recommend it it's got a lot of the same
kind of mystery feeling to it a lot of
cool world-building going on in just the
first episode so I would definitely if
you liked mr. robot you'll probably like
that too even if you're not into
superheroes and comic books and all that
it's definitely not required it's also
not required to have read the original
story if you don't want to go back and
do that let me know in the comments what
you thought about episode 403 let me
know what your thinking is going on were
you disappointed that we didn't get more
idea about the alters he was worried as
I am about Elliott's new friend I mean
there's another natural twist in that
that could be too she could just already
be dark army and she may betray him
straight out in that fashion so at least
we got some good classic Elliot's
showing his real personality being real
with somebody before the other shoe
drops please like this video if you
enjoyed
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already that's it for today
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon